les amoureux viennent du monde entier
pour se marier au château Chalin la
poterie et dire qui de la roche fouco ne
passait qu'un mois par an dans cette
demeure en
Enjou un château entièrement rénové dans
les années
1850 les béniste jean-pul mazaro est
l'un des artistes choisis pour ses
grands travaux avec son épou Ida de la
roche fou voulait être à la pointe de la
[Musique]
mode il décide de construire quelque
chose titre on va appeler le chambor
enevin alors quece que vous
voulez on a beau avoir des idées très
très très très progressiste comme on
avait mazaro
voilà on a court on se met à pied baisé
devant les larochou il y a des raisons
les meubles et les boiseries sont signés
jean-pa mazaro c'est l'une des rares
demeur où l'on peut encore voir les
pièces monumentales conçues par les
bénistes Jurassiens une fois les
châelins partis une colonie de vacances
a pris place les grands-parents de
Nicolas delonet en étaient les
gardiens moi quand j'étais petit bah je
venais m'amuser ici alors j'avais pas le
droit je le faisais sans l'autorisation
de mes grands-parents et tout ça était
vide tout ça était vidé et j'ai même je
ve le dire j'ai même joué au foot
ici ici tout le mobilier mazaro est
classé monument historique enfin ce qui
reste en fait ils étaient tellement
tellement imposants qu'ils n'ont jamais
été déplacés et ils sont scellés au mur
et puis ils ont pas été volés non plus
parce qu'ils sont tellement lourds
qu'ils ne bougent pas guimassin le GOF
ne se lasse pas de venir à Chalin la
poterie c'est le spécialiste du
néogothique en
juin on a les les motif habituel chez
mazaro et habituel également chez tous
ceux qui aiment le gothique et le
néogothique avec les lancettes de
fenestrage comme on a dans les églises
les mendorles les mendorles vous oui ça
en for d'AM Mor et les fameuses roses
tournantes que vous avez ici qui sont
toujours je dirais une des références de
Mazar on veut ici casser une
architecture trop répétitive trop connu
trop banal et reconnaissez qu'ici rien
n'est banal mais le néogothique a pris
sa place parce que c'est un art français
enfin de l'Europe occidentale qui est à
nous et que l'on ne copie pas on
interprète c'est
différent mazaro excelle dans le style
néogothique ou
néoenaissance cette chambre conçue pour
le couple Laroche fouco est dans un des
catalogues de vente de l'artiste devenu
industriel ces précieux ouvrages sont
conservés à la Bibliothèque de
lonelonnier un don de Jean-Paul mazaro à
sa ville
natale il a des meubles Phard ce qu'il
va présenter aux expositions
universelles par exemple exemplein où là
il va déployer tout un un décorum pour
montrer tout ce qu'il sait faire et puis
ensuite à partir de ces motifs il va
pouvoir créer d'autres meubles peut-être
un peu plus simples mais avec des des
des ponsifs qui reviennent par exemple
les pattes de Lyon vous avez également
des motifs floraux liés au style
Renaissance donc c'est dans cet objectif
là qu'il qu'il produit ses
catalogues parti de rien Jean-Paul
mazaro parvient à Isser l'entreprise de
sa belle famille au plus haut un article
entier lui est consacré à l'occasion de
l'Exposition universelle de 1867 à
Paris le journaliste écrit à propos de
sa fabrique de meuble commencé petite
elle est devenue immense on y a débité
des forêts c'est quelqu'un qui a sans
doute compris aussi et l'utilisera toute
sa vie qu'il faut jalonner sa carrière
de moments qui vous feront remarquer il
est présent à toutes les grandes
exposition de l'industrie et chaque fois
il franchit une étape une étape
supplémentaire donc c'est peut-être pas
ce n'est pas peut-être un calculateur au
sens péjoratif du du du du terme mais
c'est quelqu'un qui très clairement a
réfléchi et construit une carrière
professionnelle la crise économique du
Second Empire n'épargnera pas les
béniste juraien devenu parisien ruiné il
remboursera tous ses créanciers avant de
mourir à l'oupe du 20e
siècle